[Music]
good afternoon the first witness today
is Sir Frank Atherton currently the
chief medical officer of the Wales
I swear by almighty God
the evidence I shall give shall be the
truth shall be the truth the whole truth
the whole truth I'm nothing but the
truth I'm nothing but the truth
thank you
could you commence please by giving your
full name
uh yeah I'm a doctor sir Frank Atherton
and I'm the chief medical officer for
Wales
so Frank thank you very much for your
assistance to the inquiry as you give
evidence could you please remember to
keep your voice up so that we may hear
you clearly and also that your evidence
may be recorded by the stenographer
you have provided a witness statement
dated the 20th of April 2023 is that
correct that's correct yes there we have
it on the screen and it's a statement to
which you've appended your signature
thereby agreeing to the statement of
Truth
there we are
you are currently the chief medical
officer for Wales but before that
where you uh deputy chief medical
officer for health in Nova Scotia and
before that
president of the association of
directors of Public Health
so you have a long and distinguished
career in the field of Public Health and
Medicine
I'd like to start please by asking you
some questions about the position of the
chief medical officer
and the officials who assist you within
the government of Wales
may we please have up the organogram
204014 at page 10.
it's a diagram which is
um difficult to
to take stock of at first
but you will see your position chief
medical officer halfway down the
left-hand side of the large Blue Box in
the middle
population Health directorate chief
medical officer
just above that box and to the right
there is Direct General Health and
Social Services in the chief executive
of
NHS
is that the post the director general of
Health and Social Services Group to whom
or to which you report as the chief
medical officer yes it is
and that post director General reports
um does he not to the
permanent Secretary of the Welsh
government that's correct yes all right
and we're hearing from the permanent
secretary to the Welsh government Dr
Goodall next
as the chief medical officer
are you as essentially the the coral or
the central advisor to the Welsh
ministers and the Welsh government in
relation to Public Health matters
as part of which are you also the
medical director to the NHS in Wales yes
I I often think of my role as CMO in
three domains actually rather than two
but the first one as you rightly say is
to provide advice to the Welsh ministers
and the Welsh assembly and the second
one I'm the medical director of the NHS
so I work closely with the medical
directors on
um their efforts to deliver high quality
health services and the third element
which I take as a public health
specialist is to be an advocate on
behalf of the health of the population
so three roles really
if we look at the Box we can see that
the boxing to which your Post Falls as
chief medical officer includes also
population health directorate
it is that a a nod to the fact that one
of the important
aspects of the chief medical officers
role is to be concerned with
the health of the Welsh population so in
in Wales the uh the CMO role has not
been purely advisory uh it also has a um
a directorate function so a policy
function within uh the Health and Social
Service Group which is uh chose by the
director General Health and Social
Services uh so so the population Health
directorate delivers on uh Health policy
and that's Health policy in terms of
Public Health as you rightly say but but
um formerly it also included primary
care and
um uh and of course it includes Health
protection so public health health
protection it also encompasses the
function of research and development
within health
so there are a number of functions
within the directorate and is that
directorate population Health what was
formerly known as the health policy
directorate until 2008 correct to which
there are multiple references so
as part of your function then you are
concerned as the Director of that part
of the Welsh government the health
policy directorate or the population
health directorate
concerned with Primary Care Health Care
Quality major health conditions public
health and research and development in
that field indeed all right
to what extent are you responsible also
for health emergency planning
So within the um the directorate there
is a health emergency preparedness unit
and I am the lead director for the
Health and Social Service Group in terms
of emergency preparedness so I report uh
I um the the health emergency prepared
unit reports to me and I report to the
director General
so just pausing for a moment then on
that within your directorate or rather
within the directorate of population
health of which you are the director
there is a unit called health emergency
preparedness unit
we'll see a lot of that later
and through you that unit reports up to
the director general of Health and
Social Services indeed yes all right
which is the Box above you in the chart
are you
or to what extent does the role of being
the chief medical office in Wales differ
from being a civil servant
well I am a civil servant
um so I subscribe and follow the civil
service code I'm also a doctor so I um I
have a medical code that I follow
um
but the role of the CMO is slightly
different from that of any other civil
servantine that we have by custom and
practice a degree of Independence and so
I am expected to independently give
advice to to two ministers
um that's not enshrined I don't think in
law anywhere but it's a it's a custom
and practice that an expectation that
will give my advice freely and
impartially
and so by virtue of being the CMO
uh
although normally a civil servant you
are in fact in practice afforded a high
degree of
Independence when you come to report to
the Welsh government and a high degree
of separation from their day-to-day
concerns exactly so all right and in in
your experience have ministers in the
Welsh government generally been
receptive to the advice which you have
provided from time to time I would say
they've always been receptive they
haven't always followed it diligently or
entirely but they've always listened
very carefully to what I've had to say
is there a
chief medical officer directorate or
unit around you
we've heard evidence that um for example
in England there is an office of the
chief medical officer which has a number
of Staff
um and in Scotland within the direction
generality in which the CMO sits in
Scotland there are also a number of
Staff particularly concerned with
being
well they're particularly concerned with
the functions of the chief medical
officer do you have such a body around
you well I I do now
um going into the pandemic and before
the pandemic I would say I had
um you know some some support around me
but it was really quite quite a small
resource that really is quite different
now so really it was an administrative
support that was wrapped around me in
the first instance I now have an office
of the chief medical officer which
provides me with quite considerable
support in the work I do all right now
we're going to look in a little more
detail at some of the specialists groups
or entities that sit within the Welsh
government could we have
180757 uh please at page one
and I don't know whether it's possible
to do this but perhaps perhaps have it
alongside the organogram
204.014 or page 10. I should say that I
haven't alerted
um my colleague who does this to that if
it's not possible it's not possible all
right well there we have a
a Planning Group structure as at
September 2018
which sets out that the main bodies in
the Health and Social Services Group
the Health and Social Services Group and
the top line of this document is that
the group in the blue box that we were
looking at a few moments ago within the
Welsh government
I don't believe so it was just to the
left in fact and above
the directorate of the the the emergency
planning Advisory Group as I understand
it is um uh it's a group chaired by the
Welsh government Health University
planning advisor as it says but that
brings together the
um the emergency planning leads from
across all the NHS bodies in Wales
so it's not within the Health and Social
care structure it's
um it sits between the Health and Social
care and the energy yes indeed in fact
my question wasn't about the emergency
planning Advisory Group it was about the
wording at the top Welsh government
Health and Social Services Group
that is the body that we're looking at a
few moments ago on the others
on the other chart so this is
the emergency planning Advisory Group
which is a an independent Group which
normally sits within the Welsh
government But it includes a number of
different groups
will you take it from me that the
major incident response partnership on
the left and then the Wales mass mass
casualty group The Wales tne group and
the Pan Flute preparedness group are all
bodies which are on our main organogram
along with the health countermeasures
group although that's in another part of
the chart
where does HP
u h e
hietin
the the
um help you Health University planning
units coordinates the activities of the
e-pack the the as I said the
um the epag sits between the Welsh
government and the uh the local Health
boards and the hepu is the coordinating
body of that if they may assist happu is
formally within the Health and Social
Services Group which is itself part of
the Welsh government whereas this
structure is a semi-independent
structure
ports into the Welsh government one of
the reasons Milady for for producing
this document is it is a remarkably
complex
labyrinthine system we'll come back to
hebrid in more detail later but
essentially
was happy is happy the body with primary
oversight over pandemic preparedness
for the purposes of the health bodies in
Wales it certainly coordinates the
health components of preparedness yes
all right and what relationship did you
have or do you have as CMO with hepu
really my my relationship is with the um
the the the
health emergency planning advisor so
David Goulding reports to me uh and he's
the he he leads the hapu all right so
hepu is within the Welsh government it's
part of the Health and Social Services
Group that directorate which we looked
at earlier but its lead planner David
Goulding reports to you as the CMO
because one of your hats is a Welsh
government hat as chief medical officer
to the Welsh government yes yes all
right
could we have 204.014 the organogram at
page 10 please
[Applause]
so that we can get our bearings if you
go to the the large Blue Box in the
middle and the left hand side you'll see
Health and Social Services and the chief
executive for NHS Wells
I think at one stage Dr Goodall but
above that it says Health and Social
Services Group that is the group that we
saw on the other chart
and you can see on the far right hand
side of the page the
the names
Wales mass casualty Group Training and
exercise group and pre-hospital major
incident response partnership group
there's three of the bodies that we saw
in the other chart and if you look on
the very far left hand side
you will see
the Welsh government countermeasures
policy group that was one of the other
bodies we saw in the chart
and then finally
hepu is on this chart under the blue box
on the left hand side
health emergency preparedness unit but
the line goes generally to the blue box
but it actually should go directly to
the through the chief medical officer
through you to the Health and Social
Services Group in the top of the box
is that all correct
um
I can't disagree with anything you say
all right I'm very pleased to hear that
sir Frank because I simply couldn't do
that again
there is on this
chart you will see on the top right hand
corner of the right hand large Blue Box
in the middle
Scientific Advisor
what relationship do you have within the
Welsh government with the chief
Scientific Advisor
um so the chief's Scientific Advisor
sits alongside me he
um he uh he provides science advice into
the Health and Social care system
foreign
I was involved in supporting the
recruitment of that post
um I think that post originally reported
through me to the director General but
now reports directly to the director
General
oh I'm sorry I'm too big foreign
I'm talking about the chief science
officer for health this is the chief
science advice for the Welsh government
I do beg your pardon so that's a
completely separate post which is uh
employed by the Welsh government and
would be on a similar level to the CMO
expected to provide uh scientific advice
to the Welsh government impartial
scientific advice would you required
that underneath Chief Scientific Advisor
you can see within the Box NHS Wales
Chief scientific officer is that a post
which is concerned self-evidently with
health because it's an NHS Wales post
and the scientific angle of Health that
that's exactly the post I was just
describing describing now thirdly if you
then go to the left and down a bit we
can see Chief Scientific Advisor health
is that a different post altogether or
have we mistakenly duplicated the chief
scientific officer within NHS Wales yeah
I believe you've mistaken it or it has
been mistakenly duplicated I believe
very good because we can then cross that
through and simplify marginally the
chart all right
there are a number of other bodies with
which the CMO Works which I just would
like you to identify please on the top
left hand corner of the organogram is
that the UK chief medical officers group
are you one of the UK chief medical
officers
and therefore do you have regular
meetings with and a
fairly close working relationship with
the other chief medical officers in the
United Kingdom through that group yes we
do I mean prior to the pandemic of
course I've worked with two UK chief
medical officers team Sally and more
recently Professor Chris witty
um and uh with both those individuals
we've we've as chief medical officers
across the four nations we've always met
on a quarterly basis in usually in
person and then more more frequently on
an informal basis as needed
to the right of the UK chief medical
officers group we have nerve tag about
which we've had a great deal
is that a body
which liaises with the CMO and males as
with the other CMOS across the United
Kingdom in relation to specifically the
threats from respiratory viruses well it
is as you say
um I don't believe that Wales has a um a
a role or a person on nerve tag but it
is supposed to be a UK advisory body
yeah all right
in the witness statement of uh Mr
Vaughan getting and he of course is a
senior Welsh Minister and he was at one
stage I think I believe Minister for
health and Health and Social Services
um he says
the relationship with the other chief
medical officers in so far as Wales was
concerned was complicated by the fact
that the CMO in England
is not just a UK CMO but he he or she
advises the UK government
particularly in relation to areas in
which there are uk-wide ramifications
so to some extent he or she may wear two
hats English CMO and UK advisor
did you have you encountered at any
stage any difficulties in the
relationship with the English CMO by
virtue of that complicating feature of
the need to discharge UK
responsibilities
and personally I haven't no
um
the the
the two CMOS I've worked with have
always been very
um astute to the fact alert to the fact
that
um there are devolved competencies and
non-developed competencies I suppose a
good example would be in International
Development work where it's quite clear
that because it's a non-devolved
function the UK chief medical officer
sits on the Who board and has a Primacy
and International Development agenda but
that doesn't preclude the other CMOS
from having international relations with
of other countries for example so it's
never been a particular problem for me
it's it's one that we clearly understand
the the respective roles yeah so maybe a
an issue more of form than substance I
would think all right yeah
Sage is another important body to which
much evidence has been devoted we can
see it towards the top of the page the
scientific Advisory Group for
emergencies
over time and and bearing in mind that
you've been the CMO since August 2016.
have you had much involvement with sage
yourself
um I haven't had a engagement with sage
um when sage has been active and it
becomes active during emergencies of
course
um the CSA Health Chief science
Scientific Advisor for health has been
our representative on stage all right
we'll come back to this issue a little
later for for reasons that will become
plain but
did it become apparent
when the pandemic struck that
because the sage arrangement
is a UK Arrangement there was a need
within the Welsh government for tailored
scientific advice to be given to the
Welsh ministers and therefore the Welsh
government set up a different body I
don't believe we've got it on the screen
but a different body called the
technical Advisory Group tag along with
an advisory committee called Tac
technical advisory committee Were You
instrumental in the setting up of those
two bodies was that something with which
you were concerned
so yes it was
um I I discussed that with our chief
Scientific Advisor for health
and the reason for setting up Tac which
I think is a technical advisory sale
rather than committee and tag which is
the broader network of of advisors the
reason for setting those up was that we
felt that although it was very useful to
have a position on the stage we needed
to have a scientific Forum where we
could ask our own questions and where we
could get detailed at that time modeling
of course was quite important to us and
we needed more specific detailed
modeling regard with regard to Wales so
for those two reasons we set up the tack
and
all right and those there for our two
bodies that we should really have
or it should be deemed to be on this
chart
going forward this this indeed attempts
to represent the position at 2019. it
didn't exist until it didn't exist then
but but going forward they are important
committees or at least one as a cell one
is a group because they provide for a a
Welsh perspective on matters that may
otherwise be dealt with by Sage well in
fact going forwards and they would they
will continue they are continuing but
they've been renamed as science and
evidence groups science evidence
advisory groups I was about to come to
that the third body to which it should
make reference is s-tac s-t-a-c
um is that a further body which
represents perhaps a tweak if you like
on Tac and tag I'm sorry to get lost in
the acronyms but I don't recognize s
attack I recognize s-e-a scientific and
evidence Advisory Group
milady's had a great deal of evidence
about the risk assessment process
by which risks are identified owned
managed and addressed and planned for
in Westminster of course in relation to
the United Kingdom and in Edinburgh in
relation to Scotland
as the CMO did you have a hand in the
drawing up of
Welsh Centric risk assessment plans or
commenting at any rate on the United
Kingdom risk assessment process
So within the Health and Social Service
Group there was a risk register that we
contributed to and the happy would have
provided the um the the input into the
the overall hssg risk register and then
the hssg risk register would be would
form a part or would merge into the
overall Welsh government risk register
as regards to the UK uh risk ready so I
don't recall ever having any personal
input into the national risk register
that's a question
can we just break that break that down a
bit please
so in in Scotland there is a Scottish
risk assessment which is a separate
document it's a variant perhaps of the
United Kingdom risk assessment
policy or document there is no analogous
document for Wales is that there's no
Welsh risk assessment but what there is
a governmental risk register to which
we'll look at the look at it in a moment
and also a risk assessment within the
Health and Social Services Group the
hssg
baby is that correct well it is correct
that the risk assessments are exactly as
you described whether there is an
overall
um risk what was the other term you use
the risk uh register the analogous ones
that the Scottish one it's called the
Scottish risk assessment risk assessment
I I couldn't tell you uh you you'd
probably be better asking that of our
civil contingencies call the expressly
all right could we have two one five
five six two one five five six please
the corporate risk register
I believe this is the the the
governmental corporate risk register so
not the Welsh risk assessment but the
government's own corporate risk register
which
in this form January 16 was about six
months before you were appointed as the
CMO
we can see in the second column
resilience major emergencies if we fail
to provide effective leadership and
coordination and ensuring that Wales is
prepared for resilience the full range
of national hazards and threats which it
faces then there is a risk to the health
and well-being of its citizens
there are then a number of mitigating
measures or mitigating actions in the
large column in the middle controls in
place
referring to governance structures
coordination role of the Welsh
government under the panwell's response
plan physical infrastructure corporate
Welsh government response multi-agency
training programs and so on and
importantly what lessons may be learned
from incidents and development of
internal planning
as the CMO were you aware of this
corporate risk register for the Welsh
government to possess something which
when you were appointed you were made
aware of or to which you contributed in
later variants
well it's certainly something I would
have I would have been aware of
um I would have probably had more input
to the Health and Social Service risk
register which obviously fed into this
so that would be my main route of the
input I would say
on its face so Frank there appears to be
very little detail concerning the the
risk of pandemic influenza or of
mitigating actions specifically directed
towards the risk of pandemic influenza
can you recall
going back to 2016 the extent to which
that was the risk which was specifically
thought about and addressed in in the
policy guidance of the registers to
which
with which you were familiar well well I
can't recall obviously I wasn't here in
January 16 but yeah in subsequent
iterations uh certainly within the
um the Health and Social Service risk
register I would expect there to be more
detail and as of course you go you go up
through who else government then the
detail price gets lost but certainly
within the Health and Social Service
Group pandemic influenza was a um was
recognized as a material risk would you
give me one moment please
Milady that
Health and Social Services risk register
is a specific document that we've sought
but we've yet to be provided with it
statement from Mr Von getting to a
tripod earlier also says that
in a general sense
over the last five years
um and and particularly until
he personally was briefed in exercise
sickness
there had been a a lack of focus or
interest upon preparedness in the Welsh
government he says preparedness was not
a particular focus of Interest or
concern in the government
and I don't remember any significant
questioning on the topic either in
government the senate in the media or
elsewhere
was it your experience that there was
an insufficient Focus or attention paid
to
preparedness as a single issue
no I mean I I would have the way I would
articulate that would be that so his
official level there was quite a lot of
work going on around preparedness
um
as ever you know you can you can say
well could could more have been done uh
and that may be a valid question but
there was certainly at official level uh
quite a significant work going on around
preparedness that it wasn't escalated to
ministers perhaps suggest that you know
you think things get elevated diminished
as when there's a decision to be made or
when there's a problem or an
intergovernmental problem and so it may
not have come to The Minister's
attention for that reason but Senate
official level there was activity going
on through the hepu through the
emergency planning advisor group through
the local resilience for uh all of those
structures were working on emergency
preparedness
you've made reference to the United
Kingdom influenza preparedness strategy
of 2011.
was that the strategy which formed the
Genesis for the Welsh government's own
strategies or Frameworks for managing
major infectious disease emergencies and
also Health and Social care influenza
pandemic preparedness
well partly there are two different kind
of things you mentioned there first of
all the major the major infection
framework infectious diseases emergency
yes quite a mouthful isn't it yes indeed
that really sprang from the fact that we
had we have in Wales had for a long time
an outbreak control plan which is the
the thing that we use is the kind of
bread and butter too to manage any
outbreak of uh of infectious disease at
local level
going beyond that
um when you get bigger outbreaks which
affect more than one region or which are
not manageable through the outbreak
control plan the the control framework
that you just described is an attempt to
to describe how the system would respond
to those kinds of emergencies that the
the the 2011 pandemic flu plan was a UK
wide docking which we we agreed to in
Wales it informed our planning as well
in Wales but I would say that sits
alongside rather than hierarchically
around the framework
the same strategic approach however was
adopted in the
major infectious disease emergencies
framework and in the influenza pandemic
preparedness and response guidance
as formed the the basis for the 2011 UK
document correct I think the responses
would have would have been consistent
yes so the first one the first document
which I've made reference let's have
that up it's one eight three four five
six the wells framework for managing
major infectious disease emergencies
it's dated October 2014.
if we could just scroll forward through
thank you to the contents page we can
see that it it deals with
major infectious disease emergency it
provides for a number of planning
assessment planning assumptions
the management of initial cases
isolation treatment facilities treatment
in the community data collection and
countermeasures
to the extent that at all to the extent
that it did address
the possible outcomes of a major
infectious disease emergency or whatever
pandemic influenza
was the approach of this framework the
assumption that the greatest risk was a
pandemic influenza
the risk of a new and a high consequence
infectious disease was less
and the most likely catastrophic
consequences would ensure from a
pandemic influenza
so the broad approach from the 2011
strategy
well I don't I don't think the framework
was predicated on pandemic influenza
because we already had the 2011 pandemic
flu plan the the framework that we're
looking at was really designed to cover
a range of of infectious diseases which
would not be manageable through the
normal application of the outbreak
control plan so so I I don't think
they're quite the same thing I mean
certainly flu would fall within the
scope of this framework I would agree
with that and certainly
pandemic you know in terms of pandemics
flu was seen as the most likely
infectious agent to to cause a pandemic
indeed and if you look at
countermeasures 14 on page 15 I'm not
suggesting we go to it but you can see
in the index infection control and PPE
vaccination antibiotics antivirals the
presumption the working presumption was
wasn't it that
the countermeasures would be those
usually associated with dealing with a
influenza outbreak namely
the existence of antivirals Tamiflu
vaccination because there is a flu
vaccine of course and the infection
control in PPE would be hand washing and
sensible personal hygiene methods as
well as the PPE required for the
treatment of flu that was how the
document approached it well you can say
it's true but you could equally apply
those countermeasures to cholera or
measles or a wide range of other
infectious diseases I don't think it was
specific to to flu the the framework
we're looking at there was no debate was
there sir Frank or any discussion of the
sort of countermeasures that might be
suitable for dealing with a
High consequence infectious disease with
catastrophic consequences that was not
pandemic influenza for example
Mass diagnostic testing Mass contact
tracing
how to deal with an hcid that had no
antiviral and no vaccine no no you're
correct those countermeasures were not
considered within this framework or
indeed within the 2011 plan
precisely could we have one say that
we're not may I no of course
I I said they were not
um
not dealt with I mean they were
considered that they had been considered
of course but discounted for various
reasons and with the benefit of
hindsight uh discounted without
sufficient consideration thank you
116-503 is the response guidance of
2014.
it itself avidly refers across to to
influenza pandemic preparedness
if we look at page three please
we we can see pandemic countermeasures
in box four
antivirals National pandemic flu service
antibiotics face masks and respirators
consumables vaccination Specialists
respiratory support so self-evident the
incentive given that this is a influenza
pandemic document those the sorts of
countermeasures that are associated with
an influenza pandemic
a third important document to which
you've you've already made references
the pan Wales response plan of 2019.
what was that
well the pan Wales response plan is an
overarchy as I understand it's an
overarching uh plan for dealing with any
civil emergency in Wales and it's the
part of the Civil contingencies approach
of working with Partners across Wales to
respond to anything whether it be a an
infectious disease flooding fires
um any threat to put the Public's help
the public all right that was a document
which as you say deals generally with
civil contingencies it it it's concerned
with emergency response and Recovery is
that correct
so if we may put that to one side on the
basis it wasn't concerned with pandemic
influenza or high consequence infectious
disease
the two main guidance documents remain
those two documents to which you've
referred us the Wales framework of
October 14 and the guidance document of
February 2014.
do you know whether either of those two
documents was updated after 2014 or the
subject of consideration for the
purposes of being updated or Rewritten I
don't recall them being updated I think
when we updated the outbreak control
plan there was a question raised by
probably of Wales as to whether
what what the status of the the
framework for infectious disease major
emergencies would be and at that time it
was not updated but
um so I don't believe that there has
been a process to update them
now in in the history of United Kingdom
emergency preparedness
the swine flu of 2009
but was
um crucial wasn't it because of course
as a result of that swine flu outbreak
there were a number of reports
outcome documents as they're called
both in Westminster but but also in the
default Administrations
um
there was one in Wales a report produced
after the event by Mr Goulding who was I
think the head or maybe now is the head
of happy to which you've referred can we
have that please 89599
page four
eight nine five nine nine page four
paragraph 5.2
so as part of the morning session a
presentation was made
by Dr John Watkins on the risk and risks
and effects of pandemic influenza
current threats were described as
genetic reassortment and then over the
page please
novel virus
natural reservoirs the return of old
enemies planning assumptions to consider
virus will arise somewhere else a novel
virus with little background immunity
traditional groups for seasonal vaccine
not applying
issues about virulence and
transmissibility and vaccine not
immediately being available but anti and
antivirals having some role but not a
Major Impact role of masks social
distancing skilled closure Banning Mass
Gatherings Etc little evidence of
effectiveness
so this document in October 2013 after
the swine flu pandemic shows that this
presentation or Workshop there was
some debate
revolving around the inherent
unpredictability of a respiratory virus
of
the possibility that there would be an
outbreak for which there would there
would be no vaccine immediately
available for which antivirals would
have no Major Impact and in which they
would have to be consideration of some
of the additional countermeasures not
normally associated with pandemic
influenza
social distancing School closure Banning
Mass gatherings
and I wanted to ask you sir Frank to
what extent when you took office in 2000
or you took your post in 2016.
do you recall there being any general
debate about these topics
in the Welsh government
no I don't recall there being any
um I I think this document is
um a summary from a workshop that was
held and the the health emergency
planning Advisory Group that we talked
about earlier which is the NHS bodies
coming together with Wells government uh
Health and Social care has an annual
conference and I think in 2013 uh they
that their annual conference was focused
on pandemic flu and I think this is
probably a record from that um from that
meeting
um but and this clearly the the um the
lines you're you're showing here clearly
are part of a presentation given that
that uh that thing I suppose you know
what to me it says is that that was the
understanding at the time that you know
different viruses could emerge and could
cause a pandemic I think it was clear
that was clear in the 2011 this up to
the 2011
pandemic flu although it was largely
based on pandemic flu it was stated I
think in the 2011 strategy that other
viruses could could cause
um other respiratory of pathogens could
cause
um pandemics as well but the
understanding at the time was that those
final assumptions you know the master
search distancing there was a
predisposition against those which I
think is being reflected in this
document
so to draw the threads together
the two documents the Wales framework
for managing major infectious disease
and the wells Health and Social care
influence of pandemic preparedness and
response guidance both of 2014. were
never updated they were based upon or at
least
consistent with the UK 2011 strategy
and whilst there was some debate at some
levels of the Welsh government about
these planning assumptions and the
possibility that they might require
being challenged
that they may not necessarily hold true
neither the guidance nor the challenge
to those planning assumptions were ever
taken forward in a significant sense
prior to the pandemic hitting Wales
that's the position is it not
well as I as I read what's in front of
me it's not a challenge to the it it's
stating that the the role had very
little the role of these County measures
had very little evidence you know with
the benefit of hindsight I think we we
could and should have paid more
attention to the the what if questions
you know what if the virus was so
different that we needed to uh to to to
go down some of these but at the time I
think it's fair to say that that those
measures had been considered and
somewhat prematurely dismissed
there was as it turned out a distinct
and important role for face masks for
Mass diagnostic testing for Mass contact
tracing and as we all discovered to our
cost mandatory quarantines so it wasn't
just a question of
these measures having no efficacy
thinking was never developed there were
no papers or policies drawn up to
examine any of them in detail
and it was just assumed that there was
nothing here to be seen or to be further
thought about
the thinking went into the ground yeah I
accept that was the your point that was
the Assumption the 2011 strategy and it
was the Assumption in the Hein report
before that so yes that is true and the
overarching guidance documents for
pandemic influenza and hcids were never
updated alongside this yeah exactly and
they were based on the 2011 flu and they
themselves were based on yes the sinking
from 2011. I'd agree with that all right
exercises and institutional learning
before your
tenure as chief medical officer Wales
commenced in August 16 and exercise had
taken place in Wales had it not in
October 14 namely the Welsh part of
exercise cygnus
was it the Welsh part because exercise
signals for the United Kingdom was
planned for 2014 but for a variety of
reasons never took place other than in
Wales
that's my understanding that it was
planned as a uk-wide exercise but I
think Ebola got in the way in terms of
UK participation but there was a
decision taken as you say before my time
to uh to run it in Wales just to test
the local Arrangements could we have
please 107 136
these are the recommendations from the
Welsh part of exercise thickness the
part that took place in 2000 and 14.
um wrpt the acronym the top right of the
page is I think of reference to Welsh
resilience protection partnership team
partnership team thank you sir Frank I
knew you'd get there ahead of me
exercising his recommendations
background as a result of the ongoing
high risk of an influenza pandemic it
was agreed that a tier one UK exercise
should be held on October 14 exercise
sickness to assess preparedness of both
the national and a local level but but
as you say the UK exercise never took
place
there were initially 11 local resilience
forums scheduled to participate at the
local level in England whilst Wales all
four local resilience forums agreed to
take place if we could just scroll back
out we can see the Strategic objectives
there set out
and further down the page
the reference to the postponement of the
UK exercise cygnus could we have then
over the page page two
issues raised
the following are the issues and
recommendations to emerge from the
Strategic coordinating groups and the
Wales civil contingencies committee
pausing there
as you understood it was the position
this that because it was only the Welsh
part of exercise sickness that took
place in 2014 the exercise focused on
the local level the local resilience
Forum the Strategic coordinating group
level rather than being a test of the
entirety of Welsh civil contingency
structures
it's my understanding but it was two
years before I took it post I can't
really comment a huge amount on that
so Frank you're plainly aware of that
from the face of the document because it
is only concern with local resilience
forums and strategic coordinating groups
and presumably once you became chief
medical officer you were briefed about
exercise cygnus in 2014 and the extent
to which the recommendations which were
about to return were being implemented
were you not I don't remember a specific
briefing about it but I would have been
aware of it as we went into 2016 cygnus
exercise yes because that was the
delayed United Kingdom exercise to which
the Welsh government was a participant
yeah and you were no doubt informed
and you probably asked to what extent
are the recommendations from the first
part of cigna's been put into place by
now yeah I I can't remember the
discussion about that but yes all right
well on this page we can see the issues
raised concern excess deaths
just
the the Practical problems associated
with dealing with large numbers of
fatalities communication
regulation
the reduction and there's an example the
need for two signatures on a death
certificate resources a reference to a
national stockpile of resources school
closures
demands for data collection and
concern being expressed by one strategic
coordinating group about the national
pandemic flu service and then over the
page if you scroll back out please
vulnerable people so those were the
lists of concerns raised and then
scrolling back out please again
the recommendations that are that are
made towards the bottom of that page you
can see recommendations one through to
nine
concerning antiviral collection points
equal position of Staff movement it
Health Board needs
a reference to the need for
um
decisions at a national level to be made
by the Welsh government in respect to
the NHS world and at local level
criteria
I'm so sorry when it moves it's quite
difficult to follow it criteria for
declaring a flu pandemic five Welsh
government department for education and
skills to update guidelines six lrf
coordinators group seven
working arrangements for the wells
pandemic flu group and Wells warning and
informing group eight and nine Welsh
government social services and Wells
Mass fatalities group
to what extent do you recall sir Frank
those recommendations being implemented
by the Welsh government by the time that
you took office in 2016.
um well there's a quite a complex range
of them we'd have to go down for trucks
individually but um I the the way in
which from exercises the various
exercises that we had and this was one
of several of course before my time and
during my time the way in which those
recommendations were being managed was
that there was a database spreadsheet
which was maintained by the happu and
that did log the recommendations and and
regularly track the progress against
them so somewhere in the system there
will be a document which which says at
that point in time in 2016 when I took a
post to what extent they were met and
then subsequently they would have been
updated
can you recall in a general sense
whether all the recommendations from the
first part of cygnus were implemented I
can't win all right
the recommendations did not cover or
consider
some of the areas which have turned out
to be vital to the response of course to
the covid pandemic for example
surge capacity or
any need to stop pal or provide for PPE
in the sorts of quantities which which
proved to be necessary or any of those
other areas of countermeasures to which
were referred was that because
first part of exercise sickness was only
concerned with relatively quite a low
level in The Civil contingencies order
down that tree of civil contingencies I
I think it's partly that right and
partly that um
it it's back to the point that it was
predicated on what had happened in 2009
and the pandemic that we've been through
so there's a lot of consideration in
there about the distribution system for
antivirals in 20 2009 we had to set that
up from zero as indeed subsequently we
had to set up a lot of structures for
covid from zero but that those are the
two reasons I think why
why it is what it is why the
recommendations are what they are right
that's very clear
then moving forwards to the main United
Kingdom exercise cygnus in 2016.
it was in October so you would have been
imposed
you were appointed in August
was the Welsh government a full
participant in the exercise do you
recall
uh well it was a participant and
ministers were involved officials were
involved and um so yes we were we were a
participant in that
in terms of which parts of the Welsh
civil contingency structure came under
examination and were called upon to take
part in the exercise was the Welsh
participation more limited than the
Scottish participation because it had
had its own albeit quite local exercise
cygnus in 2014 already that may well be
the case I don't recall the details but
I don't recall that we tested the lrf
structures in the set quite the same way
I could be and probably because we had
done that in 2014 all the Strategic
coordinating groups one presumes because
they had also been the subject of
examination in 2014. I I can't recall
them being tested all right
do you recall can you recall the extent
to which those two documents the Wales
framework for managing infectious
disease emergencies or the Wales Health
and Social care influenza pandemic
preparedness and response guidance were
tested in the course of the 2016
exercise cygnus they would have been
background documents but really my my
role in cygnus was at the officials
level meeting with the CMOS and
supporting the minister so so that was
the kind of level I was working at the
May well have been further consideration
you know further further into the system
there were official groups meeting in
Wales as I recall and they would have
certainly had access to all of those
documents
after exercise cygnus
the ladies had evidence that
the
NSC thlc a ministerial Committee in
London in 2017.
ordered the setting up of a pandemic flu
Readiness board
in London and also one followed in
Scotland
and
um
are you aware of the extent to which or
how the Welsh government responded to
that direction from the NSC thrc
in Wales what body was set up by where
the pandemic flew preparedness group in
Wales to deal with the aftermath of
exercise sickness
so the pandemic flu Readiness group at
UK level was set up and Wales had a
um an input into that again through the
hepu it was the Prime uh the prime
relationship with with Wales
and then in 2017
an influenza pandemic
preparedness group was established Again
by the hepu to to to to to to tie into
the recommend to the work streams let's
say that were being run through the the
UK group
so the same Wales pandemic flu
preparedness group to which I referred
that is the body that responded in Wales
it is yes could we have 107 112 please
these the minutes from the first meeting
of the wells pandemic flu preparedness
group in September of 2017.
and we can see that there are a number
of attendees from the Welsh government
and public health Wales
and there is hepu of the top health
emergency planning unit
um
although I believe that hepu formally is
known as the preparedness unit but in
any event maybe that's an earlier
emanation but we can see a number of
officials from the Health and Social
Services Group
HSS Public Health whales and apologies
from three further officials
further down the page
paragraph 1.4
an official and and
um
the the official for your information so
Frankie is a senior member of hepu said
that he'd call this group together to
coordinate any outputs from the UK
review structure and consider what may
need to be undertaken in Wales to
implement the review outcomes so so that
is what you said a few moments ago the
group was formed in order to consider
what should be done in Wales 1.5 the
same official added that he thought
there were a number of strategic
documents that may need to be changed
following the review including the UK
pan flu framework 2011 that's our our
old friend from 2011. the local
resilience Forum pandemic flu Guidance
the Wales response plan the Wales Health
and Social
service pandemic preparedness and
response plan and the UK Wales pan-free
communication strategy and the
operational pandemic flu guidance
related to NHS and social care
do you know the extent to Frank to which
any or all of those documents
did
get
updated in the fullness of time
um yeah I don't think any of them were
finally finally updated I think that the
whole process was to uh of the the UK
process was to update the the suite of
guidance so the pandemic flu framework
was being
and that was a pandemic free plan wasn't
it 2011. yes it was was was being
updated through the group we just talked
about
um there was a an expectation or a hope
I think that the lrf pandemic flu
guidance which I think was 2013 was
going to be led by by Wales uh and and
the others um I don't think have been
updated since then
if you could turn please to page four
and paragraph 7.1
we we can see that
the group decided that future meetings
would be convened as and when
substantial progress have been made at a
board or work stream level
is that a reference to to the point that
you've already made which is well you've
made a few moments ago which is that
this committee or group decided that it
couldn't progress
the updating of the Welsh plans
in these various areas unless and until
the United Kingdom group
had updated the United Kingdom plan the
2011 strategy was that that's the
roadblock well that's my understanding
this this group essentially was
shadowing the UK preparedness group yeah
but this group so Frank was convened in
order to be able to progress civil
contingency emergency preparedness
planning in Wales
what was the point of it convening at
all if it was only ever going to do
something once the United Kingdom had
acted first well it was it was to
provide input as well into that into the
UK process so
um the uh the the the meeting of the
group you know I think further up than
the minute there
um talks about which members of the uh
the Welsh government were to be linked
into the various strands
of UK preparedness so it wasn't just
waiting it was actually looking to how
we in Wales could support the overall
development of pandemic preparedness if
you go up to 6.1 please there's a
reference to
strategic approach being applied members
of the group should take the opportunity
to look at the operational guidance
currently in place and review whether
revisions or New pieces of guidance
would be needed following proposals from
the Readiness board he added that he was
taking a strategic approach to the task
and any concept of operations developed
would need to be reflected in Wales at a
local level what do you understand that
reference to taking a strategic approach
to mean
I don't I don't really understand that
at all though
this was the position wasn't it that
although that group was convened in
order to progress Welsh civil
contingencies work
none of the pieces of work that were
identified as requiring
updating refreshment whatever it would
you call it was done
even though some of it
plainly included
guidance that was Welsh only so not just
the United Kingdom documents or policy
but Welsh documents none of it was done
because the view appears to be taken
that nothing should be done
until the United Kingdom
pandemically Readiness board had acted
first in relation to its own 2011
strategy I think it's fair to say that a
lot of the subsequent actions were
predicated on hanging off the revision
of the 2011 plan strategy yeah
so
the board this group decided it wouldn't
convene again until further progress be
made at the UK level
those are minutes from a meeting in
September 2017. in January 2018 were you
contacted by the United Kingdom pandemic
flu Readiness board and asked to agree
to a meeting to see what progress was
being made yes
and to that meeting not take place for a
further six months until June of 18.
I think that's correct could we have
180482 please
senior officials meeting with Welsh
government dhsc and cabinet office
Cardiff 14th of June
we can see that you are named as the
first attendee from the Welsh government
called Patrick
about whom we've heard and about to whom
we'll learn a little bit more in a
moment directed for local government
and David Goulding to whom you've
referred emergency planning advisor
a major constituent part of hepu
Miss Hammond from whom a lady has heard
direct a civil contingency Secretariat
um page two please
an official asked whether any
vulnerability mapping had been conducted
as part of the sector resilience work
there was some discussion about
challenge panels
DG Mr Goulding noted in the Welsh
government
a group have been established to
consider the outcomes of the UK
reviewing to coordinate Wales actions to
implement any necessary changes in Welsh
planning
so Mr gulling makes reference to the
point you've made which is that nothing
was going to be done until the United
Kingdom had acted first but what about
documents which were only Welsh
documents as opposed to United Kingdom
documents
did that approach affect guidance across
the board in the field of pandemic
planning there was no document that
could be process um
could be worked on and improved or
updated because of this strategic
approach well I think the the master
document was the was seen and was always
seen as the 2011 strategy release I
think
and this is just my recollection that I
think that everything else was was seen
to be hinging on on that having said
that you know there were groups
um through the um the emergency planning
Advisory Group that we talked about
earlier which we're trying to progress
to work on excess mortality Etc so so
some of the work was continuing but
there was no
um updating of the overall strategy
documents that was all hinged on the
2011 strategy update and the 2011
strategy itself hinged on whether or not
the UK pandemic flu Readiness board
would have the resources of the
inclination
to do that first step of updating it
itself didn't it I can't disagree with
that if you look at the second bullet
point under products the 2011 strategy
Refreshers are scheduled year two
pandemic flu Readiness board product
I think product there is a
piece of jargon to me meaning work while
a refresh of the 2013 local resilience
Forum guidance is needed this is not
currently scheduled in year two of the
program primarily due to Resource
availability
in terms of timing there would be
limited benefit in refreshing the head
of the strategy given the cross
references needed between the two
documents so the UK pandemic flew
Readiness board was unable to get on
with its own
refresh of the 2011 strategy because it
was for different reasons tied to
another document which wasn't even going
to be addressed until the following year
because of resource problems
following that meeting what concern did
you have that the entire
process of bringing these important
hcid and pandemic influenza panwell's
documents up to date was being
frustrated
well I think the there was an exchange
Associated exchange between the hepu and
civil contingencies group and the note
went to the minister to to advise that
all the progress was being made it
wasn't as fast as we had anticipated and
that there was a likely ask for
additional resources not least around
the refresh of the 2013 lrf guides which
as I say I think there was a my
recollection of the meeting was that
there was an expectation that Wales was
going to provide some leadership and
some resource into that particular piece
of work
so uh so the the note went up to the
minister about that yeah but that
expectation was never realized was it
what expectations the expectation that
you've just referred to which is that
there will be LL local resilience Forum
guidance updated nevertheless no I think
events kind of overtook things yes right
so that never happened either it did not
right could we have please
180484 this is the email string to which
you've referred so Frank
it's an email string from July 2018.
it's going to be a bit difficult to find
the relevant emails because it's all on
a single page but
for excellent technician can find his
way down to the 6th of July 2018.
which is probably two or three
screenshots lower
6th of July um and then o4
13 so 13 minutes past four in the
afternoon it'll be two or three further
emails down
from reg Kilpatrick to Frank Atherton
yourself and David gilding copying in
Andrew Goodell who was then the NHS
Wales chief executive but is now the
permanent secretary
was this an email
in which between you all because you
were all concerned with this issue
concern was being expressed about the
fact that the review and the guidance
was was simply not being processed
if you look down at the third paragraph
that Kilpatrick said to you given that
this is a UK review they that's United
Kingdom government are specifically for
some resources to help in that task but
it seems a reasonable request in view of
the total emergency planning capacity
across NHS Wales I would expect us to be
more Cooperative than we currently are
pace of development of the review and
guidance is therefore at risk so this
needs to be exposed to ministers along
with resource issues
and it was brought to ministers was in
odd it was
um it was indeed yeah so that was the
net that the um
uh this all refers to a minute of that
meeting which was being sent up to being
prepared to be sent up to the minister
yeah and is that Mr Vaughn getting to
whom we've referred earlier who was then
the cabinet secretary for Health and
Social Services yes
so this email correspondence was at
official level where you were debating
your concerns about the fact that there
had been no progress and that there was
an issue about resources
and a risk
administratively or politically which
needed to be brought to the attention of
Mr Getty
is that a fair summary because he's a
fair summary yes
the the email string ends on the 10th of
July if we go back to the top of the
page
where you wrote this
after they've been quite a
quite a difficult debate between the the
three of you so Frank about um what
should be done
um I don't think we need to go into the
the detail of of what became quite quite
a personal debate further down the email
chain but you said signal that we have
reached a compromise there is
considerable work remaining we need to
deepen liaison with the local resilience
Forum mechanism but I'm assured we have
good engagement with Department of
Health on this
so your position was why don't we tell
the minister
that
a compromise has been reached in terms
of the extent to which the United
Kingdom can call upon the Welsh official
structure for assistance but there is
considerable work remaining on the well
side we need to deepen liaison but we've
got good engagement
is that a fair summary of what you were
saying really partly is the the
compromise was
dare I say you know between members of
our team really was in Welsh government
because there was a something of a
disagreement about the the advice that
we were giving to the minister so
um there was a feeling from the Civil
contingencies side radical Patrick that
uh the The View we were giving to the
minister in David Goulding's original uh
email uh
message to the minister was unduly
optimistic and that we weren't signaling
sufficiently the need for additional
resource or the request that was coming
from the UK government for additional
Welsh resource and where that resource
would come from so the compromise was to
change the the advice that was going up
to make it much clearer to the health
Minister that those were Salient issues
so presumably some advice or
a message was sent to the minister for
health
in the event in the event uh sir Frank
is this the position though that
no further resources
work
as far as you understood it committed to
pandemic planning
the risk that you'd identified remained
which is that the Welsh government would
be exposed the accusation that no
further resources were being devoted to
this issue
no further work was done in relation to
any aspects of the Welsh pandemic
planning guidance because of the
roadblocking as you saw it in London
and this particular body which had been
set up in order to progress work the
Wales pandemic flew preparedness group
met for the last time
in September 2018 and didn't sit again
I I agree with all of those those points
and and of course the reasoning behind
that was that the reason for that and
for the progress then to storm was that
resources were moved to other issues
yes it
is that a euphemistic reference to the
impact of the necessary preparations for
a No Deal EU exit or operation
yellowhammer if you like yes
so
not only were no resources developed not
only did no work continue on the
guidance not only did the main committee
dealing with this issue not sit again
but whatever work streams were being
pursued were then interfered with by
operation yellowhammer is that a fair
summary the work all stalled
so it stalled for additional reasons yes
looks like we're not going to finish the
Frank ly for the break
my lady if that's a convenient that may
well be a very convenient moment but yes
I'm afraid that is the reality
sorry we're gonna have to break off in
the middle of evidence okay I shall
return that boss
three
all right
thank you
so Frank in May 2018
according to your witness statement you
re-established a body known as the
health protection advisory committee
and it had representatives from the
Welsh government local Health boards
Welsh local authorities the food
standards agency Public Health Wales
national resources Wales and and a
couple of other entities
it plainly
covered a range of Public Health matters
or was designed to cover a range of
Public Health matters and not just
influenza pandemic preparedness or even
hcid preparedness but
why did you do that what need did you
perceive was not being met
in the absence of such a committee or
what concerns did you have if any that
led you to want to re-establish that
committee
yeah so
um
there had been a committee a health
protection committee previous to my
taking up the role of CMO and that was
disestablished for reasons I don't
really understand but my desire was it
was really to have a forum where we
could look at the broad sweep of Health
protection issues which affected a range
of organizations
um uh the the reasoning for that was
that you
Health emergencies health issues health
threats to health
so wide-ranging that you need to have a
lot of different organizations involved
and engaged so although I've had very
good contact with health counterparts
and social care to some degree I didn't
feel we had it strong enough input to
local authorities to
um to Natural Resources Wales to the
health and safety executive to the food
standards agency so I I set the
committee the group up to bring together
those things it was really a stakeholder
group to help to understand the threats
and so they could bring to the table and
to my attention any threats from their
particular domains as well
does it follow sir Frank that
the need for that committee was born
from the recognition that there was no
other pre-existing committee which was
it was convened was being convened to
address such threats or to look at those
Health protection issues
there was nothing looking across the
broad sweep that I've just described yes
and in the course of
the
the 18 months from May 18 to the onset
of the pandemic did that Health
protection Advisory Group look at a
number of threats or issues or matters
of concern it is yes
one of the ones that we've noted was
the the areas in which hospital
isolation facilities may have been
deficient
I'm not going to ask you questions about
that but there was an issue about the
Improvement in compliance and
what the substantive provision of
facilities amounted to
but another important area which
followed on from that was the issue of
high consequence infectious disease
outbreak control
did you have a concern
that
the position in Wales the the structure
that the personnel and the people and
the systems for dealing with
hcid high consequence infectious disease
outbreak was deficient
um
so they are as you rightly say two
different things they isolation rooms
issue it had gone back quite a long time
and I was I had tried to uh to to make
sure that in Wales we had sufficient uh
isolation room
um availability in all of our Hospital
stocks so that we could deal with
significant infections and to help to
control
communicable diseases within hospitals
the eight said issue High consequence
infectious disease issue it came came to
my attention particularly when we had
cases of monkeypox now mpox and Ebola
occurring in the UK
and it was clear to me that having high
consequence infection units only in
London and Newcastle as I think it exist
at the time we had a gap in Wales and I
felt that we ought to have some
provision in Wales and so we used to
embarked on a process to develop that
provision as part of the UK Network
but what provision the provision for
dealing with high consequence infectious
disease yes exactly yes but so there was
no or at least no adequate provision
for the
management of a high consequence
infectious disease in Wales until you
directed the committee which you
re-established to look at that issue now
there was provision the provision was
predicated though on the use of uh
hospital beds in London or in Newcastle
so any High consequence infectious
disease in Wales would have had to be
transported those places and in fact
just so just pause there
there was in Wales territorially no
provision for the treatment of high
consequence or the management of high
consequence infectious disease
if you became infected in Wales with a
high consequence infectious disease your
management the treatment and the public
health consequences would all be
transferred across the border just to be
clear we're talking about very unusual
infections Ebola infections for example
where highly specialized contained
facilities are required at a level that
we did not have in Wales we had we
hadn't have the ability to treat most
infectious disease most outbreaks Etc
but H says is a separate it's a higher
tier provision of service which
currently exists only in those two
places I've mentioned what we had done
of course in Wales is to make sure that
if we did have such a such a case if we
had a case of Ebola that we were able to
identify it isolate it the the person
who was affected and transport them
safely to to one of those units and we'd
actually invested through the world
sampling service in the arrangements to
make that open
injuries were not adequate were they
that is the concern that was expressed
at the committee which you set up that's
why I was concerned that we should have
such an establishment in Wales exactly
so it's no answer to say well it's all
right they were perfectly adequate
Arrangements in England to dealing with
hcid the committee
became aware that quote we in Wales were
not adequately prepared for such an
incident and that was a reference to
two Welsh residents from Welsh West
Wales who had been low-risk contacts of
a
um
I suppose a sort of Ground Zero but the
zero monkey
's case yeah so so the Welsh system was
unable even to deal with a case
involving just two contacts from a
monkey pox infection well I accepted the
point that it was it was the case as any
any High consequence infectious disease
that was identified in Wales or indeed
light squares of England would have had
to be treated in either London or
Newcastle those were the only two sites
I felt it was important to it's like
that's not to say that the arrangements
were were not there there were
Arrangements but I wanted to strengthen
those arrangements
email thread between you and some of the
officials on the committee including Mr
Goulding of the 31st of December 2019
says
it became clear that we were not
adequately prepared for such an incident
so it wasn't a question of the committee
saying we are adequately prepared
because we can make arrangements for
contacts to be traced in England or for
somebody infected with monkey pox to be
treated or managed in England the Welsh
response
was not adequate isn't that the reality
well it was adequate in if we had
something we would we would we had the
arrangements to get them to a hcid
facility that was that was that that
would have solved the issue that would
have provided the support to that person
but it would be a better system perhaps
a strength and system might be a better
way of putting it than an inadequate
system we were trying to strengthen our
system well could we have please one
seven seven three seven nine up please
on page one
[Applause]
you can see that the email is addressed
to David so David Goulding if you could
just cast your eyes down please the page
sir Frank to the reference to monkeypox
case
yes
so in the context of how the system had
been tested by recent events where two
Welsh residents from West Wales
who are low risk contacts
I had come to the attention of the NHS
the planning meeting to confirm how we
would respond to one or both residents
becoming unwell it is it became clear
that we were not adequately prepared for
such an insulin so this debate was not
phrased in terms of well we're doing
fine but we could do even better it was
we were not adequately prepared that
that's not the same is it
well I I accept your point but you know
I I
perhaps it was an inelegant wording on
my part we could certainly have
responded to those uh patients because
we would have we had robust plans to get
them to an eight-seed unit what a
perhaps should have said is adequately
resource to manage such an incidents in
Wales which is what we were trying to
set up
well let's have a look at the minutes
one seven seven three eight two
please
at page three at paragraph 4.2 there is
a reference to
an issue relating to Care Homes
which paragraph please 4.2 CMO is that
you that's me yes Express concerns about
the preparedness of care homes in
particular the arrangements for
antivirals
this was in the context of seasonal flu
was it not it was yes so
in relation to seasonal flu for which
there is necessarily antiviral in
existence and and vaccines and a
national
flu service
you were expressing concerns about the
ability of Care Homes
and the arrangements for antivirals in
that limited context yes
can I can I expand on that please lady
would I help so in in Wales we do have
arrangements for provision of antivirus
into Care Homes when we have seasonal
flu it's rather
um a laborious process in that it
involves getting General Practitioners
involved and that is a real draw on
their time I had come across from Canada
where I'd been working in similar
environments but in Canada we had a much
more robust system I felt where uh Care
Home has had pre-order pre-authorization
to distribute antivirals on the say-so
of a CMO or a medical officer and it was
a much much more streamlined process and
I had discussed with ML uh the the
bringing that that process into Wales so
that's that was the nature of the
discussion at the hpac meeting thank you
all right that's care homes in relation
to
infections page four paragraph
5.2 please
High consequence infections
presentations CMOS is that you
'll establish that acknowledge that
there were significant questions about
the preparedness of NHS whales to deal
with a similar situation but one monkey
pulse case and two contacts and to be
able to manage an infected case at one
of our acute hospitals for at least 24
hours
so you you weren't saying there it's all
fine
may we please have more robust plans
which is the phrase you used a few
moments ago
you acknowledge there were significant
questions about the preparedness of NHS
Wells of the Welsh NHS to deal with this
limited case of a monkey pox infection
purely yeah I I accept the points
absolutely but it was because monkey pox
was defined as a high consequence
infectious disease and we were not
geared up to provide all the facilities
needed all the Staffing or the
arrangements to provide treatment for an
hcid in Wales and I felt that was a gap
in our arminence which we which we
should improve
and so by contrast
to the catastrophic consequences of
covid
which in essence is a
highly infectious disease just not
terminologically a high consequence one
with catastrophic consequences there
wasn't just a gap there was a yawning
Chasm
in terms of preparedness the Welsh NHS
couldn't even deal with a single limited
contact hcid case
well I think they're very different
things the the the if you remembered
to go back to at the start of the uh the
pandemic
um
because we knew very little about
coronavirus the novel coronavirus it was
true it was managed initially as a high
consequence infectious disease and
patients were transferred to London or
Newcastle the first few patients
beyond that of course it it became
downgraded from a high consequence
infectious disease to a disease which
should be able to be managed and could
be managed within hospitals that had
adequate infection control procedures
and normal hospital secondary and
tertiary care facilities so so there is
a very significant difference between
the one case of Ebola or monkey pox and
the large number of flu cases which we
were absolutely geared up to deal with
or indeed subsequently of the
coronavirus cases so I accept your point
that we were not adequately prepared for
high consequence infectious diseases
which is why I raised it with the hpac
and tried to to move that to and in fact
we've made some Investments through the
National Health protection system to
actually start to address that
what general concerns did the committee
Express about the absence of testing
capacity in Wales and it's
current microbiology estate that is to
say the structural the system
for dealing with new testing
Technologies and
testing diagnoses and Frontline support
well I don't think the committee
commented specifically on that remember
the committee was to give advice to me
but I had had discussions with public
health Wales colleagues about our
adequacy in those regards and we'd
sought some additional investment to try
to strengthen again those processes in
Wales I think we sought extra resources
from the minister in 2019 and then
subsequently in 2020 when the pandemic
hit
could we have
177362 please
this was a paper prepared for the
committee in July 2019 six months before
the pandemic struck page one at
paragraph four
the current microbiology infection
services in Wells are fragile and are
struggling to deliver on a day-to-day
basis that prevention early diagnosis
and Frontline support the Professionals
in the public require
is that not a major concern it was a
major concern that's why I was Raising
it so that we could get extra additional
investment to address it was additional
investment provided within the six
months following this paper I believe it
was
um we we provided we we put advice to
the minister and the minister uh
provided some additional resources we
also moved some resources within Public
Health Wales so I think an additional
1.5 to 2 million pounds was invested in
our laboratory capacity
and in um the workforce capacity to
needed to deal with uh major outbreaks
and incidents so Frank that money May
well have been attributed
directed towards the fragile
microbiology infection services in Wales
were any additional testing processes or
Personnel for testing made available by
the end of December 2019. well I don't
know about the recruitment process that
went through but certainly the the
funding was in 2019 was put in was
intended to improve the testing
specifically around genomic testing of
pathogens
by the onset of the pandemic
the entire testing provision
the
microbiological the genomic the
diagnostic testing system in Wales
remained fragile
as we can see here
did it not there was a fragility that we
had to address and that's why in 2019
we're trying to start to address it
final questions please in relation to
inequalities
and and appreciating a course that as
the chief medical officer Wales you you
are not the minister for Health and
Social Services
can you recall any Focus being
paid at any time
either in terms of the guidance or the
policy documentation or the procedures
which which came before you
upon
the impact
on those who suffer from societal or
ethnic inequality of all this planning
other than in relation to the obvious
point that um
will always be clinical risk involved
and and obviously
pandemics and disease outbreaks affect
everybody differently clinically
can you recall any debate at all about a
wider
consideration of societal or ethnic
inequality
so the the the one I can recall there
being quite a bit of discussion about
was about how we this is not specific to
pandemics but how we in any civil
contingencies issue whether it's
flooding or
flu or anything how we kind of identify
vulnerable people and Target resources
towards those vulnerabilities
um so there had been quite a a bit of
work in Wales about how we map
vulnerabilities and how we in fact what
transpired as I recall from the
discussions was that there was every
different organization had different
methods of doing it and what I think we
where I think we landed was that there's
a need for a common approach to
vulnerability mapping of vulnerable
individuals and vulnerable groups in
society who might need additional
support on top of the support you get
through any any major incident
all right thank you
those are all my questions
um you've granted permission for a
number of errors to be explored by the
legal representative for covid-19 brief
Financial Justice company thank you it's
happened
thank you Milady so Frank I'm just over
here right of the pillar
um
my name is Kirsten heaven and I
represent the covid-19 brief families
for justice Camry I just want to explore
two topics with you the first one is a
bit more pleasing in relation to
infection control
obviously you'll understand that this is
a matter close to the heart of many of
those whom I represent particularly in
the context of those who contracted
covid-19 and went on to die in the
context of of Hospital acquired
infection
I first want to ask you in particular
about a document so can we bring up
please inq30s
one four five seven two six
huh
so if we just scroll down we can see
so this is a document entitled
Healthcare Associated infections a
strategy for hospitals in Wales and we
can see it's a Welsh assembly government
document now just to give you a bit of
background we know that this is a
document from 2004 so clearly it's a
very long time before you come into Post
in 2016 but if we just look if we just
turn to the first page please
we've got it on our screen have you
sorry it's not showing on my screen oh
sorry yeah okay so we can see that this
is
um there's a forward here and it's
explaining that there's a healthcare
Associated infection
um some patients will become infected as
a major consequence of another illness
and it's talking about a strategy being
developed by the Welsh Healthcare
Association infection subgroup of the
committee for the control of
communicable diseases and essentially
it's setting out a strategy to be
applied in local NHS trusts in Wales
um to essentially improve infection
control in Welsh hospitals
first question did that subgroup on the
committee for the control of
communicable diseases did that exist in
2016 do you know
um I don't recall it uh I don't recall a
group of that name but we did have
various groups looking at
Healthcare Associated
infections yes
scroll down then briefly to internal
page four
do you have that there okay yeah so we
can see there that in the basic
introduction Healthcare Associated
infections continue to cause substantial
patient morbidity and cost of the Health
Service and it's explained in the second
paragraph that there's a reference there
to an improving Health Wales document
from 2000 which is the essentially the
inspiration for this document in order
setting out clinical tools for the
management of infection control
so if we can turn then internally to
page 25
do you have that there
um I have a page I can't tell what
number it is but yes so page 25 I what
this is what I want to ask you about is
some lessons from the severe acute
respiratory syndrome outbreak paragraph
1.5
do you see that there yeah okay
so what this document uh essentially is
saying is that some lessons needed to be
learned as a result of the sales
outbreak in 2004 and I'm not going to
read it all out because the inquiry has
it there before then but what it makes
clear is the SARS outbreak has this
provided us with a timely reminder that
not only should sound and evidence-based
infection control policies be in place
but considerable attention must be paid
to ensuring that they are rigorously and
consistently applied
and this requires sound understanding
and commitment to effective infection
prevention and control practice amongst
staff in the Healthcare System
and the strategy focuses on the
development of systems designed to
achieve this objective so that was the
clear recommendation coming out in 2004
that there needed to be it
systemic policies developed within
infection control
now just fast forwarding then to 2014
you've been taken to the wales's major
framework for managing major infectious
disease emergency so just to complete
the picture if we could get that
document up please it's inq3 zeros
and it's page 13.
so it's internal page 13.
now you've been asked in detail about
this document I want to focus on the
very last bullet point which says this
all hospitals need to establish ways of
caring for large numbers of infectious
patients on a scale outside their normal
experience including those requiring
High dependency care can you see that
there yes yeah
so you've been asked about the adequacy
of Wales ability to respond to one or
two cases of a hcid but in 2014
following on from the SARS
recommendations it
it was recognized wasn't it that there
was a need for hospitals to deal with
large numbers of infectious patients not
just one or two
that's certainly the case and we see
that every year of course with pandemic
with seasonal flu outbreaks indeed
so when you came in to your post in
you just assist the inquiry with what
personal steps if any did you take
um to ascertain the state of infection
control generally in Welsh hospitals
so um
when I arrived quite early on I actually
chaired a group which was looking at
antimicrobial resistance and also
Healthcare Associated infections I
co-chaired that with one of the medical
directors from one of the local Health
boards and that group was subsequently
taken over by the deputy chief medical
officer who was reporting to me so we
did have through all of the time that
I've been the chief medical officer and
continue to have a very strong Focus I
would say on hcai's Healthcare
Associated infections
um we we we we have the structures in
place we have the guidance in place to
hospitals is what they should be doing
around
hcai's and infection prevention
we monitor that as Welsh government
Health and Social Service Group
monitored it very carefully through the
monthly returns from from Health boards
and from through a process called the
jet that's the joint executive team
meetings where we meet with the
executive of each Health Board
twice a year to and we look at well a
range of issues but including infection
control issues
um and it's why I in 2016 when I saw the
the lack of
um
uh
total provision of infection control
isolation rooms across Wales why I
personally put so much time and effort
into trying to get the resources to be
able to make sure that every hospital
and every health facility had the
ability to deal with those but more
fundamentally
um I I was regularly in contact with in
common with my colleague the chief
nursing officer at the time and we we
wrote repeatedly I think to uh to to
Chief nurses to Medical directors
reminding them of their responsibilities
and we actually established I think it
was in 20
I can't remember which year but we we
established a workshop probably as early
2019 actually to to look at the issue of
um uh hcai and our health protection
system and that what led to the
investment that we've just been talking
about with Mr Keith so you know you
asked what personally I've done I think
I've tried very hard to make sure that
hcii remains an important consideration
within the health system and that we
have the ability to to deal with it but
we've seen that the recommendation in
2004 was in relation to SARS that was a
hcid wasn't it
it would have been an hcid yet it was
only in 2019 that you were raising
concerns in relation to Monkey pox
another hcid yeah so quite to delay
wasn't it well
um
I'm talking about the the the the
generality of infection control in
hospitals and that's a really important
issue and I thought that's what you were
referring to but if your point is that
we didn't have an hcid facility in Wales
until uh
um you know up until 2019 that is that
is correct correct but we did have of
course as I've previously outlined
arrangements for patients with hcids to
be safely transferred to English
facilities for treatment
just one final point in relation to
nerve tag please you've just explained a
moment ago that
um Wales didn't have a role in nerve tag
I think we understand from the evidence
that we're likely to hear from Andrew
goodhall that Wales played an observer
status and we can see in documents in
2016 nerve tag are making
recommendations about the need for ff3
P3 masks and more General masks to be
available in all hospitals communities
and ambulance and social Care staff
services
in 2016 and onwards were you personally
aware then of the recommendations that
were being made by nerve tag in
particular in relation to masks that
I've just described well I don't recall
seeing that recommendation I'd have to
have a look at it but
don't you need to know in your role as a
CMO if nerve tag are making
recommendations isn't that something you
need to know I would expect to have been
informed of that and I would expect that
the systems in Wales would have picked
that up and wouldn't know about that as
to whether we were a member or had
Observer status I I I can't recall that
some of the the groups in in the UK we
had Observer services and it may well be
the case that we did have observices in
which case Milady I apologize for my
earlier statement but we can we can
check that but to be clear you never
attended a nerve tag meeting directly
yourself I did not no no thank you very
much lady
thank you Miss Heaven one question for
me so Frank you described almost at the
very beginning of your evidence that
um the office of the chief medical
officer when you first started sounded
like it was pretty under-resourced
it got the resources when you went and
when we went into the pandemic
so what did it go from too
well essentially Milady
um
I had secretarial support and personal
Administration support for you know but
what transpired at the start of the
pandemic is
um things have moved very very quickly
and we very rapidly realized that we
were drowning under the sea of
information we couldn't manage the
information flows couldn't even manage
emails and so that led to a process over
a period of time with me working with
the director General you're about to
speak to to try to get some additional
resource so that that was the process we
went through
so basically the getting the additional
resource was an acknowledgment that you
were under resourced in the first place
thank you
my lady may I just correct one matter
which is that um
I put to Sir Frank that we had not
received the Health and Social Services
Group risk register
the Welsh government has kindly informed
us that they did provide it in fact last
Thursday
but I regret to say that it didn't pop
out the far end of the material provider
disclosure process in time for
um I've learned from Mr Sharma myself to
be able to be aware of it
I should have said Malone friend respect
her not
Mr Sharma
so Milady the next witness is Dr Andrew
Goodall the
permanent secretary to the Welsh
government
I swear by almighty God that the
evidence I shall give of the evidence I
shall give shall be the truth shall be
the truth the whole truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth and
nothing but the truth
good afternoon could you give the
inquiry please your full name my name is
Andrew Goodall
Dr Goodall could you
remember to keep your voice up as you
give evidence please for our purposes
and also for our hard-working
sonographer
I believe my lady will be sitting until
shortly before five o'clock so there
won't be a break this afternoon and of
which you can take advantage but there
may be tomorrow
um
you will I'm afraid of giving evidence
tomorrow morning as well it's impossible
to conclude your evidence tonight you've
provided
three witness statements have you not
variously dated the 14th of March 23 the
20th of April 23 and the 20th of April
23. yes I have I think it's fair to say
Dr Goodall you've trained every sinew to
provide us with as much information as
you can about the workings of the Welsh
government
each of those statements is true is it
Norton and you've appended your
signature to each of them it is true and
I've appended my signature thank you
you are currently the permanent
secretary the sole permanent secretary
to the Welsh government are you not I am
I took a flat post in November 2021.
before that where you director general
of Health and Social Services and
therefore also the chief executive of
NHS Wales posts which you held between
June 2014 and November
2021. uh yes that's correct and I was
discharging that role during this
particular period yes which is why of
course
um the previous witness Frank Atherton
referred to you
in the run-up to the pandemic as being
the director general of Health and
Social Services indeed that's great
could we start please with a crash
course in
Welsh constitutional matters
and
the role of the Welsh Parliament
formerly the National Assembly for Wales
the role of the Welsh government
formerly the assembly government and
where
Health public health and civil
contingencies come in the devolved
nature of things
so
there was under the government of Wales
act in 1998 a National Assembly for
Wales established is that correct yes
that's correct and within that
National Assembly was there an executive
known as a cabinet or an executive
committee which comprised members of the
assembly yes that's correct
in 1999
a broad range of functions previously
exercised by Ministers of the crown
for the United Kingdom in London were
transferred by way of a series of orders
in Council
to the executive the cabinet or the
executive committee in Wales
is that correct yes and and were they
the transfer of functions order or
orders of 1999 and following uh yes they
were
the
in 2014
under the Wales Act
did the name of the Welsh assembly
government
become change or get changed to the
Welsh government
uh yes it did it change to Welsh
government
and
in 2020 did the name of the National
Assembly for Wales change to the senate
or Welsh Parliament uh yes those changes
happened in 2020.
so over the course of time
the nomenclature as well as the
functions of the cabinet or executive
committee
in essence the Welsh government have
changed quite considerably have they not
yes indeed they they have changed
significantly in particular when the
opportunity to be able to make its own
legislation came through
and was that because until the
government of Wales act 2006 the
National Assembly for Wales was unable
to make its own primary legislation yes
that's correct
and so the current position
is this that in the Welsh government
there is a first Minister who leads the
Welsh government is that correct yes
that's correct and there are a number of
Welsh ministers equivalent to what what
might what one might call Senior
ministers in the United Kingdom
government in London and Deputy Welsh
ministers
equivalent to Junior ministers in the UK
government
uh yes that's correct their their names
have changed over the years but broadly
uh it would be the same yes and there is
that the Apex
of the administration of the Welsh
government a permanent secretary and
that is you yeah yes I lead and manage
the Civil Service yes so you're
I suppose might call the equivalent
amalgamation perhaps of head of the
Civil Service in Wales the cabinet
secretary the administrative chief
executive you are the permanent
secretary who is subject only to
ministerial control yes that would be to
my successes myself from 2021 of course
and yes my role would include acting as
the principal accounting officer for the
organization and also acting as the
first advisor to um to the first
minister in the cabinets as well
we've seen from the relevant paperwork
that Wales does not have Ministries
it has for the purposes of carrying out
its functions a number of departments
known as
directorates yes
is that why we've seen of course in the
context of Health emergencies repeated
references to the Health and Social
Services directorate indeed Health and
Social Services Group and I was the
director general of that group indeed
until you became the permanent secretary
in your witness statement one of your
witness statements you say this
despite the range of responsibilities
the Welsh government is and in my
experience always has been a compact
Administration
Welsh ministers and Senior officials are
Under One Roof and frequently in the
same room together
what consequences have flowed from that
Dr Goodall in terms of the way in which
the Welsh government has been able
historically to make decisions as I've
experienced it through this particular
period but of course subsequently as
well um I think it allows for a closer
contact amongst both officials and also
amongst ministers
it means that irrespective of working in
an individual portfolio for example in
health you have an awareness of the
broader workings of government including
on other policy matters I think it does
create a network of confidence and Trust
colleagues get to know each other and it
also extends out Beyond just the
workings within Welsh government because
it translates into the way in which we
work across other agencies and other
networks in Wales as well so there is an
intimacy about that system internally
for Welsh government as well as outside
doctor girl you speak very fast and I
didn't in fact ask you the beginning to
to speak more slowly or to ensure that
you speak so could you please do so
however of course it's very difficult
for the
the the
very skilled stenographer to keep up
with that level of of speech
just to identify the major moving Parts
at the highest level of the Welsh
government is there a Welsh government
board which provides strategic advice
and assurance
to you the permanent secretary
yes I would distinguish its role aside
of course from the cabinets and the
political oversight which also will
oversee the delivery of civil service
priorities in Wales but the Welsh
government board has a role to help me
discharge my principal accounting
officer role it provides Assurance it
helps us with the Outlook and the
Strategic direction of the organization
in simple terms it allows me to lead and
manage the organization
and do you also have the benefit of an
executive committee which is a
both an operational and strategic
decision-making body within the Civil
Service in Wales
no doubt staffed by heads of the
directorates and and other officials and
and chaired by you
yes we have an executive committee I
chair it and that really acts as the
decision-making mechanism for the Civil
Service and finally it is that and this
become relevant later something called
Iraq
arac the the audit risk Assurance
committee which assists you to to
discharge the functions to which you
made reference a moment or two ago as
the principal accounting officer to the
Senate you are responsible to the Senate
as the principal accounting officer for
the entirety of the Welsh administry
non-ministerial Administration
yes the auditory risk committee
um supports the again the discharge of
the risk areas in the organization the
annual accounts process and brings
together non-executive members alongside
directors and officials in the
organization
devolution
the inquiry is now very familiar with
the distinction between devolved and
reserved matters
our health services in Wales almost
entirely devolved which means that they
are within the responsibility of the
Welsh
ministers and the Welsh Civil Service
yeah yes they are almost entirely uh
devolved I would describe them as
devolved there are some exceptions
around some specialist areas which will
occur on a UK basis but yes they are
devolved responsibilities by contrast at
the beginning civil contingencies were
not
all devolved were they
no they weren't all devolved clearly
there were Welsh responses from First
Responders through the government but
they weren't all devolved
responsibilities at the time back in
2004. and that is a reference isn't it
to the Civil contingencies Act of 2004
of that year because that was a single
legislative framework or provided for a
single legislative framework for both
England and Wales along with
the statute itself the provisions in the
statute and also the statutory and
non-statitary guidance which
was produced alongside the ACT yes
that's correct and it also gave us
equivalence around support Arrangements
like local resilience fora
and
historically under that act were a
number of regulations made
by way of secondary legislation which
applied to both England and Wales uh yes
they were
in the fullness of time however and
following a number of reports into civil
contingencies in Wales and notably a
commission on Devolution in Wales the
silk Commission in 2014.
was there a major change in 2018
primarily through the Welsh ministers
transfer of functions order
which gave
at least for the purp purposes of the
first part of the Civil contingencies
act part one the 2004 Act
Powers exclusively by way of devault
matters to the Welsh government
yes whilst it left part two Arrangements
still at the UK level
um those were the arrangements that came
over for part one in 2018 and reflected
a lot of support to want to be able to
transfer over those functions very
clearly into Wales because the previous
Arrangements
um
probably had Welsh government acting in
a de facto leadership
function and role but actually the
legislation was able to make that very
clear
by that do you mean that from 2010
onwards and until 2018 the Welsh
government appreciated that because it
was the government on the ground
so to speak dealing with public health
dealing with local emergencies because
of course they arose locally
it had to take up
the role of of acting de facto as a
responder under the Civil contingencies
act even though that was a piece of UK
legislation
and even though it wasn't formally a
devolved matter yes it would have a
coordination and support role
um but because of its discharge of
default responsibilities through
ministers it needed to have Clarity on
its involvement
in many respects a lot of that
leadership had been discharged in the
world's resilience for uh from at least
2003 so Welsh government was trying to
ensure it was able to give that
coordination role but again we needed to
make sure that the powers were much
clearer which is what happened in 2018.
could we look please just at one of
those reports which I've referred the
reports on civil contingencies which
preceded the transfer of of functions
order it's a report dated the 6th of
December 2012 one zero seven one one
three
and perhaps we could pick it up at page
four please
Dr Goodall
oh
I'm
putting this page to you because
although this is dated the 6th of
December 2012
over 10 years ago
I'm going to suggest in due course that
some of the problems and concerns
identified back then
are still relevant to this inquirer's
consideration of
the run-up to the pandemic
even though
this report was prepared at a time when
the Welsh government had pre
transfer of devolve functions a very
different role
the recommendations were these many of
the arrangements to deliver the Civil
contingencies act 2004 were well but the
role of the Welsh government is unclear
and there are opportunities for
increased efficiency in local delivery
complex leadership Arrangements have not
prevented the Welsh government from
providing effective support for partners
delivering the Civil contingency act
2004 is that the de facto role to which
you've referred uh yes that's what I
would have been describing
but too many emergency planning groups
and unclear accountabilities add
inefficiency to the already complex
resilience framework
could I perhaps go straight to the heart
of
the line of question which I will
develop over the next two or three hours
and ask you this which is
do you believe looking back that that
problem identified in 2012 was
adequately addressed
by 2020
had that inefficiency and over
complexity
been rooted out of the Welsh civil
contingency structures or do you think
they remained I think we had addressed
that in part in terms of allowing the
Welsh government role
clearer particularly where ministers
would have expectations
to oversee public services and discharge
their responsibilities
I think that there is an inevitable
complexity about bringing agencies
around the table who have a series of
different reporting Arrangements
up and through to UK departments there
are non-devolved responsibilities
for example the police
and I don't feel that any of that has
got in the way of creating Partnerships
and relationships in Wales but in simple
terms we rely on an emergency response
that is driven from a whale's resilience
Forum structure and is supported by four
local resilience for areas
I think the complexity of course is
every first responder having their own
statutory responsibility which means 22
local authorities for police forces 10
health organizations and I think that
probably does start to steer some other
difficulties but I think we at least
were able to
address an understanding of Welsh
government's role but I do think that
some of the supporting Arrangements in
place up through local resilience for
Arrangements
would still need to have been worked
through
your answer appears to address
primarily the
the arrangements at local level the
local resilience forums and the
Strategic coordinating groups and the
resilience Partnerships and so on
but is that
isn't that conclusion on that page
of more General application that there
are too many emergency planning groups
and unclear accountabilities in the
resilience framework so across the board
so not just at local forum strategic
coordinating group level but within what
has now become a more crystallized part
of the Welsh government
I think there are Arrangements that work
differently when planning and preparing
which turn into something different in a
response mode so I would say that we
need to have an understanding of the
difference between those two areas
I think that some of the individual
points of
working Arrangements that take place and
some of the detailed level of work has
inevitably need needed a level of
expertise and experience to be applied
so I would have some concerns about the
range of subgroups
that can appear that can be used
constructively
but we would have needed to have made
sure they had a task and finish Focus
rather than just becoming a embedded
part of our machinery
I think the interrelationship between
the use of different Frameworks and
plans at different times for me would be
an issue
um
we actually had tidied up some of those
arrangements even back I think in around
2012 because the Infectious Disease
framework as an example was an amalgam
of four previous parents but
nevertheless I think that the
interrelationship
between
pandemic Health and Social Services
responsiveness and preparedness guidance
alongside the Infectious Disease plan
alongside the pan Wales response plan
we still I think need to make very clear
about what parts of those are working at
which moments and certainly in my own
understanding just to help with the
clarity of the issue it's the panwal's
response plan which is the overall
coordinating and guiding hand if you
like on the arrangements in Wales
Dr Goodall
the paperwork demonstrates that there
are a plethora of different bodies from
the wells whales resilience Forum the
Welsh resilience partnership team the
Civil contingencies group The Well civil
contingencies committee the resilience
Steering group
s-tac the Tactical Advisory Group cell
the Tactical Advisory Group the
emergency coordination Center the Civil
contingencies and incident response from
The Joint Emergency Services Group hapu
to which we've just had some evidence
directed
have the panwell's response plan there
are a multitude of guidance documents
there was a swine flu
a Wells pandemic influenza response
Arrangement swine flu task and Finnish
group a Wells pandemic flu task and
finish group
Wales pandemic flu preparedness group
I haven't covered them all
for for a Administration which Prides
itself on its efficiency of movement
because of the the relative lack of
scale
and and an Administration that operates
effectively Under One Roof are there not
in fact
plethora
of of bodies in this labyrinthine system
there are many bodies I think some of
those relationships are probably clearer
to me about how they would work I think
some of them would feel as though that
they were duplicating some of the tasks
and activities
and certainly the balance of what is
discharged nationally as opposed to what
is discharged within those sort of local
responders and in the regional
Arrangements of the local resilience for
it would also be an issue but yes that's
a very significant list of areas and
looking forward
in our safe and secure ways of course we
need to make sure that that is very
explicitly set out that it is clear and
it is also efficient
um what I also don't want to lose within
our assessment though is the times when
we do need to of course deal with issues
that a matter of detail but again as I
said earlier I think that needs to be a
philosophy of task and finish
rather than ongoing Arrangements
sorry I don't follow task and finish
I think I do yeah yeah task and finish
groups really just to make sure that
they quickly handle an issue
um they may have a cycle of two or three
meetings with experience and expertise
around the table and then come out with
a solution which can be implemented
rather than an ongoing set of meetings
that's a response uh our response so as
an example
um if one is working through a response
about
excess deaths in the context of pandemic
flu
to ensure that there is a time scale
that is given in order to achieve those
and deliver them and not just be an
ongoing contact point between those
experts
task can finish
following swine flu
the Wales resilience partnership team
agreed that a Wells pandemic flu task
and Finnish group be established correct
yes following exercise cygnus
the Welsh resilience partnership team
delegated overall responsibility to the
Wells pandemic flu preparedness group
and following exercise cygnus the
pandemic flew Readiness board was
promulgated instituted for the purposes
of making sure that that
those recommendations were identified
and finished
but would you agree that despite those
three instances of task and
finish
functions being identified
not all
the recommendations from any of those
reviews or exercises were in the event
implemented
not all of those were implemented so and
those committees those task and finish
bodies
took in some cases a very long time to
attempt to ensure that the relevant
recommendations were implemented did
they not in my view they took too long
to make sure that the recommendations
were implemented even if there had been
progress on some of those activities and
matters and they were completed
and so despite your recourse to the
benefit of task and finish bodies
history and the reality has shown that
they themselves have not really
performed terribly well have they
they haven't been able to discharge the
outcomes on all of those areas and
we need to understand how
if we have got to a better place that we
need to be able to update the guidance
at that point rather than try to keep
searching
please may we not have a terminological
debate they have not done very well have
they the the Tasker Finnish groups did
not deliver all of the objectives they
didn't achieve them no I agree
they were given the task but they didn't
finish
they didn't achieve all the tasks by
lady yes
rather defeats the purpose of a task and
finish group does it not
could we go back to
107.113 please
page nine
paragraph 13.
this is the paragraph which underpins
that conclusion which is in red at the
top of the page which I read out from
the index page
that the role of the Welsh government
was unclear in the opportunities for
increased efficiency in local delivery
so in 2012
one of the concerns expressed in this
Welsh audit office report concerning
civil emergencies in Wells was that
there was a distinct need for increased
efficiency in local delivery that is to
say the practical application of civil
contingencies Arrangements
and that there was a confusion about the
role of the Welsh government
and I asked you what your view was on
this a little earlier but we've now had
the debate about the task and finish
committees would you now
perhaps reassess that some of the
problems identified in this report from
continued
right up until the onset of the pandemic
because the committee process the group
process the structures in the Welsh
government continued to be in
significant respect
inefficient
yes I would agree with you that
um
there were too many Arrangements in
place at that time
that may have changed our focus and what
was needed
as I said earlier I do think that some
of those mechanisms occur because of
preparedness as opposed to
the response itself but uh yes I would
agree that there is an ongoing need to
make sure that we can have a less
complex system yes thank you page 10
paragraph 17 and 18.
foreign
too many emergency planning groups and
unclear accountabilities add
inefficiency to the already complex
resilience framework that's the the the
summary I read out earlier
and paragraph 17
generally says the current structures
leading to inefficiencies at a local
level are necessary complexity and
unclear accountabilities and at 18
complex reporting arrangements are
leading to confusion about the roles and
responsibilities of the numerous
emergency planning groups and
organizations the complexity risks
fragmentation of resilience activity
with potential overlaps or gaps in the
arrangements for resilience
that is a astute and precise summary is
it not of the Welsh government civil
contingencies Arrangements between 2012
up to the time of the pandemic
um
I believe we had addressed some of that
complexity but to take your point
um I do agree that we have had too many
examples of
um
duplication and activities happening
even as we adopted the Welsh government
responsibilities in 2018 we
are probably still not worked our way
through the implications of that
transfer of responsibilities by the time
we take the pandemic as well
in essence the Welsh government was
faced with with a with a very complex
strategic conundrum which was having
been given
a multitude of what had then been well
up to then been reserved functions by
virtue of the transfer of functions
order in 2018.
somehow those new responsibilities had
to be discharged
and that of course required a great deal
of thought to be given to the best way
of setting up the system the Committees
the groups the entities the responders
and so on to be able to do those new
functions indeed that's correct and we
had just in 2018 started to do some of
the resilience Assurance within the
system in Wales at that point
um but were unable to continue with that
as a cycle as we'd originally intended
but that was very all in in the transfer
of the responsibilities and
as a result of
inevitably with all governments resource
issues
as a result of the diversion of
attention away from civil contingencies
planning to
the consequences of a No Deal EU exit
and of course the impact of the
catastrophic pandemic work was never
allowed to get very far
yes we haven't yet passed regulations
that would discharge those part one
responsibilities as an example but
certainly as you say the EU exit
Arrangements ended up being a priority
over and above some of the underlying
resilience activities that's correct
maybe now then look at some of the
bodies
and and see
to what extent that proposition in that
paragraph was justified in terms of
unnecessary overlap and at the same time
gaps
the first body to which you refer or the
first part of the Welsh government your
statement is the Welsh government
resilience team could we have pleased
the organogram
at page 10.
[Applause]
somewhere
oh yes middle mid on the far left of the
page please of the diagram halfway down
Welsh government resilience team
although on this
representative
diagram the Welsh government resilience
team is shown as being outside the Welsh
government box the the first Minister's
box in the middle of the page and the
directorate for Health and Social
Services the Welsh government resilience
team is we presume within the Welsh
government it is within the Welsh
government and it helps the Wales
resilience Forum to coordinate its role
and works with the other agencies in
Wales is it within a directorate within
the Welsh government or is it a
self-standing separate entity it's not
self-standing it's within one of our
directorate stretches
was it originally located within the
community Safety Division in the Human
Resources Group but then transferred to
the community Safety Division and local
government then moved to education and
public services
yes that's correct it stayed uh in
consistent Arrangements linked to the
local government roles in particular
yeah
is it going to stay where it is now or
might it move again Dr Goodall
um both that team including an expansion
of that team as well is still currently
located within the same director General
arrangements and is still Associated
around those public services and local
government areas
do you think it likely that it will
remain in the education and Public
Services Group and then within the sub
Community Safety Division or is it going
to move again
uh
it's it will be staying within those
group Arrangements all right
there is evidence perform a lady that
that resilience team
attempted to procure or at least the
Welsh government attempted to procure
additional resources and funding
from the United Kingdom government in
order to better enable the Welsh
government to discharge those functions
which were transferred
formerly being
Reserve functions to the Welsh
government under the transfer of
functions order 2018.
are you aware of whether or not those
requests for further resources and
funding to deal with these additional
issues were successful the transfer of
responsibilities happened but there was
no funding that came across with those
responsibilities from UK government
so we had to review those arrangements
ourselves at the time
I believe there's a witness statement
formulated from Mr Kilpatrick who was a
senior official in the Welsh government
um in in which he compares unfavorably
the amount of funding and the Staffing
levels for the
Welsh government resilience team to the
analogous organization in the Scottish
government
does the Welsh government acknowledge
that that resilience team is even by the
standards of
pre-pandemic
and and post-pandemic civil
contingencies planning under-resourced
and On Demand
it was
under-resourced at the time and it
expanded and it has continued to expand
but there are lots of examples in our
discharge of our responsibilities in
Welsh government where
irrespective of having a wide range of
responsibilities we still however remain
a compact organization
so uh
I know at the time we did expand the
resources for that team they have
subsequently been expanded on the back
of experiences including of course
during the pandemic itself
I believe that in 2022 a new
director it was formed within the Welsh
government called the risk resilience
and Community safety directorate is that
correct uh yes that's correct
are all resilience functions in the
Welsh government now within that single
directorate
for the better purposes of transparency
and accountability or are they still
diffusely arranged across a broad
spectrum of the government and they are
mainly located there but it doesn't
remove the individual responsibilities
that are held by ministers and also by
directors general for
other sectors across Wales but as an
example
for health emergency planning unit would
still be sat within the health
structures as part of supporting the
coordination of those responses
but that unit has expanded to include
areas like cyber security response and
does act now as the sort of expert
facility within the organization so
there is now a primary risk and
resilience directorate within the Welsh
government
so that everybody may know that that is
the director is in charge generally of
civil contingencies but in the context
of Health emergencies and civil
contingencies plainly there needs to be
another body dealing with health
resilience and emergency planning and
that is elsewhere in the world's
government yes we um line manage the NHS
in Wales and it would form part of those
responsibilities but of course they
would need to be you know very closely
liaison and coordination in the Welsh
government context
there is in Wales a whale's resilience
forum
which was created in 2003 and I I think
at least as some say it's chaired by the
first Minister and made up of senior
leaders or Partners in the Civil
contingencies field in Wales
similar to what we've heard is the
Scottish resilience partnership does
that whale's resilience Forum which is
obviously a wider body still function uh
it does still function uh whilst there
may on occasion be deputizing
arrangements for the first minister in
my experience the first Minister has
been the lead
Minister for that Arrangement and has
been a routine
mechanism for meetings and discussions
in Wales in preparedness and planning
mode
uh genius
technician has flagged up Wells
resilience Forum on the screen does that
body give
direction to another body called the
Wales resilience Forum uh sorry does the
Wales resilience Forum give strategic
direction to what is known as the Welsh
resilience
partnership team the Wales resilience
partnership team are there to support
the function of the Welsh resilience
Forum so it's where the civil servants
are located who will act as the
Secretariat and who will oversee the
arrangements by linking out with the
wider system in Wales
can't it just be a single body Dr
Goodall
the whales resilient forum and the wells
resilience partnership team if that is
simply the operational
mirror of
the Strategic forum
do they have to be two separate bodies
the Wales Brazilian forum is a is a
meeting which is supported by the team
so it discharges the range of
responsibilities but
that is just the supporting team but
they do have a role beyond the
Secretariat they of course act to link
out
to Partners and agencies in Wales as
well
what then is the Wales civil
contingencies committee on the top right
the Civil contingencies committee will
actually meet in the early phase of an
emergency response rather than being
chaired by the first minister or a
designated Minister it will be chaired
by a senior official
um and that allows it to understand its
responsibilities within a response phase
of a major incident or an emergency
planning issue
so what's the difference between a civil
contingencies Group which is the box in
the middle of the yellow box in the
middle and the Wales civil contingencies
committee
the Civil contingencies group
establishes itself in the early stages
of an emergency response the whale civil
contingencies committee is when the
triggers have been identified and when
we are moving into a proper emergency
response and it acts as a liaison point
with cabinet office and the UK
government Arrangements including where
needed to give advice up to the Cobra
Arrangements of course
foreign
what then is resilience Steering group
which we
may or may not have
the resilient Steering group from the
chart is is just a smaller subset of
colleagues um because the wealth civil
contingencies committee inevitably
involves a range of agencies and other
colleagues around the table it's just a
small interface that allows the
activities from that group just to be
taken up to support some of the liaison
as well
so the whale civil contingencies
committee is a wider group of colleagues
who act to give advice when we are in
response mode
coming back to what you said earlier
about the the I don't know the doctrinal
or or theoretical difference between
preparedness and response
is this duplication of bodies in part
the result of a need to be seen to be
having a separate committee that deals
with preparedness then that which deals
with response I mean generally the
approach the point that you'll recall uh
Mr Man and Professor Alexander
um addressed what now seems some time
ago yes indeed uh for example the Wales
resilience Forum
um didn't have a role to discharge
within the pandemic response because it
was there to prepare and to bring
agencies together under the auspices of
the first Minister but yes it's to
separate out the preparedness from the
response Arrangements that are
operationally occurring at the time
there is in the bottom left hand corner
a body known as scientific and Technical
advice cell
stack
are you familiar with that body yes
and we believe that was
set up or at least radically changed in
July 2019
why was that
uh just to try and ensure that
um whilst needing to rely on of course
advice uh science and advice and use the
networks at the UK level
but they may well be
areas and they were experiences that
showed that they would need to translate
advice directly into the Welsh context
that wouldn't necessarily happen in
every Arrangement but on the basis of
the emergency that was
under consideration there may be the
need to draw in some more specialist
advice at that time which is when those
arrangements came into play
but Dr Goodall we've heard evidence
already this afternoon from Sir Frank
Atherton the CMO who
pointed out to me lady that there is
already a chief Scientific Advisor for
Wales a chief scientific officer NHS
Wales a chief Scientific Advisor Health
within the Health and Social Services
Group Wales has the benefit of nerve tag
any learning that comes from Sage
why was there a need for yet yet another
body
to make sure that those experiences
could be brought to bear and it would
also allow us to use those science
experts within Welsh government as well
so it was just a Connecting Point not on
every occasion or for every emergency
but when needed but it has the
Secretariat it requires funding it
requires people to fill the posts on
that sell and
has it not in fact also
transmogrified over time because there
is now a tactical advice cell and a
tactical advice group both born from and
having having their Genesis and the
scientific and Technical advice cell is
that correct yes the technical advice
cell that was introduced
basically
is in line with that particular
mechanism and was able to discharge
advice and support for the areas that
were under consideration in Wales during
the pandemic response and yes it did
bring to bear that sort of closer
understanding of modeling data and
evidence in the Welsh context and in the
context of discharging devolved
responsibilities but Wales attends Sage
so why wasn't sage and nerve tied
together sufficient and if it wasn't why
wasn't s-tac
sufficient why was ronita yet a third
level of new bodies
that the technical advisory cell attack
and the technical Advisory Group in
order to provide a forum for scientific
and Technical advice which was already
been provided by Welsh government
advisors
and available from UK entities
so Welsh government had an observer
status on stage I know that changed over
time enjoying the pandemic which was
helpful in clarifying some of the
responsibilities
we did end up converting this
Arrangement into the technical advice
Arrangements in Wales through the
pandemic response and do believe that
that allowed us to understand the
discharge of responsibilities in the
Welsh context
not to recreate all of the sage
mechanisms but to allow us to just
simply translate the implications of
that into the Welsh context including
the data and the evidence
and and finally
what is the difference between the
emergency coordination Center
which is a we understand is a is a Welsh
government well as it says on the 10
emergency coordination Center and the
Civil contingencies and incident
response team
the um the emergency coordinating Center
is a
physical response which involves the
coordination activities and is located
within Welsh government and that can be
set up fully or in part
on a 24-hour basis if needed during any
emergency response but it is a physical
entity in our local resilience for
Arrangements across Wales there are also
physical locations where colleagues and
staff do come together to actually
oversee and coordinate the different
activities
but isn't that what the Civil
contingency is an instant response team
does it comes together
as an instant incident response team
and I read from your statement to lead
and facilitate the Welsh government's
response to civil emergencies
well what's the difference
uh
TCW is is the physical establishment of
the center it's the building it's the
building ah plus where the destiny
individuals will be sat and discharges
that coordinating Focus within the
building so it's a physical
establishment and was physical during
the pandemic irrespective of course
other virtual arrangements so it was the
short answer that the Civil contingency
is an incident response team work in the
emergency coordination Center indeed
I think about as far as I think any of
us can go today
is that a convenient moment I'm sorry we
have to break off Dr Goodall but um I
think you're prepared for it and the
lady I understand
uh I shall return at 10 o'clock tomorrow
please